now in Game of Thrones do the the actors
have any chance to make the wrong I mean
something of their own and they've like
give you ideas and no ideas or more
ideas or well I mean the television show
separate from the books I mean the
actors don't have any influence on the
books but certainly they have on the
character as they've seen in the
television show now some of the some of
the characters on the television show
are very very similar to the characters
in the books but others are not for
example the German actress Sybil K Kelly
played the role of Shay a camp follower
who becomes involved in Tyrion and she
her take on Shay was much different than
the character in the books and you know
I watched and Sybil and I have become
good friends since then I just saw her a
few weeks ago she visited me in Santa Fe
but as I watched the first season I'm
watching her she is it this is this is
all wrong this is not the way I wrote
Shay she's this character is not it's
not it's it's a different shade and then
the more I watched it I said it's a
better shade per se is more has more
depth than my verse my wife her ship
Shay has more you know more emotional
realism than my shame and you know show
business secondary maybe even a tertiary
character so she in the book she mainly
functions as a foil for Tyrion but Sybil
is a amazingly talented young actress
and she took that part and gave it an
emotional residence and depth and made
it a person in her own right whose own
story was was separate from and not just
a kind of small part of Tyrion story and
you know that's what the great actors do
they they make the roles
they were owned and they can take them
in unexpected directions at the
beginning we're you okay with that I
mean at the beginning I was a little
concerned about it so I saw she was
doing and you know her Shay is better
than my share but they're both dead now
so it doesn't matter I'm sorry I gave
away people there who knew Shay was a
lot smarter than booked Shay and booked
Shay had many virtues but she was not a
deep thinker
she was just seeing the stuff that was
immediately in front of them and you
know the point where Tyrion you know
initially when he brings it to city in
the black I started with your first book
in English I told you I won the first
one yeah I didn't want to read it before
you know while I was filming and now I
bought an English one and I want to read
it in your language no no not now well
when Tyrion first brings shade to the
city in the books he gives her her own
house like a mansion with servants
really yeah he sets her up in this in
this place and he visits her secretly
when he can but when he can't of course
she's alone by herself there and and you
know she's bored so she has singers and
and and other people which he gets
jealous of so there's tension there
between them so it's a quite a different
dynamic yeah but David then how to
simplify it I you know the first season
that you were on yeah i knowing where it
was going I was saying because you know
she really likes Tyrion she really had
genuine feelings for him so how would I
gonna work the the the betrayal at the
end it's it's not gonna be convincing
but I think they made it convincing and
given the fact that it was genuine
feeling there
I hope it was it was more powerful